Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and I've been stranded here in
the Alaskan Bush for the last three days
and I am a long way from civilization
I'm not quite sure how things are going
to work out but it's up to me to get
myself home and uh one thing's for sure
it's gonna be an interesting video
[Music]
[Applause]
how to reach for the city lights
this thing where I belong
hey look at me more than what I've
become
and I've been wanting
looking for something I'm digging deep
these nights
what I thought was gone
[Music]
all along
I think it's time for me to go
on Bridges
all I know
I got lost along the way
[Music]
all right
There Goes My Ride
don't
[Music]
well guys that right there was the
hurricane train it's a Whistle Stop
train run by the Alaska Railroad and
it's just dropped me off in the middle
of nowhere here in the interior of
Alaska and that's what they do you
simply tell them which mile marker you
want to get off at and they stop and let
you off and if you need to get picked up
if you just wander out on the tracks and
you flag them down like flagging down a
taxi this train only runs twice a week
but I'm not planning on flagging it down
I've got something else in mind but
first I need to get my snowshoes on
let's see how she pulls
it's the dead of winter here in Alaska
and I am truly in the middle of nowhere
this railroad is my only connection to
civilization but here in a few minutes
I'm Gonna Leave This Railroad and I'm
gonna start hiking that way I've got no
Trail and at least one set of mountains
to go over
but I'm going to try to hike my way back
to civilization and for the next couple
nights I'm going to be making my own
shelter
all right this is where it gets tricky
I've got to find myself a path through
these woods I've got to climb about 600
feet in elevation once I do that it
should open up like the snow is going to
be really soft and deep in there
[Applause]
right now there's about four and a half
feet of snow on the ground and my
snowshoes are just barely keeping me
afloat on the top of it there's a layer
of crusty snow on the top if I put too
much force down or if I try to go up a
hill I bust through that cross and now
I'm in snow up to my knees and thighs
that's why I can't be wearing a backpack
that extra weight will cause me to break
through the top crust of snow
and then I go down deep
even with the snowshoes this is a lot of
work
see
all right check this out
some cranberries
you see Barry's still on the bush in the
middle of winter that tells you there's
not a lot of animals around
I'm not following any Trails so I have
to navigate by landmarks so I'm keeping
this goalie off to my right and I'm
going to follow it to the top of a 600
foot bench
all right guys this is my first major
obstacle I got to get up this 600 foot
bench but when I'm pulling my sled
uphill it puts a lot of extra weight on
my snowshoes and I bust through that
snow and I sink way down deep then I'm
just wallowing in the snow trying to go
uphill but this is a big make or break
moment for this trip if I can't get up
this bench
I've got to come up with a plan B we're
going to try to hit this at an angle
foreign
just wants to pull me right off the hill
[Applause]
there's so much time and energy just to
get this little distance
oh just sinking your foot sinks down and
then you've got to lift your foot all
the way up here just to get to the next
step
I made it to the top of this little
Knoll but that's by no means the top of
the hill because once I get to the top
of this bench I'm going to have to do it
at least one more time
I made some decent progress but I got to
get off that
all right I'm gonna try Switching gears
foreign
it's about to get real dark here a
little bit I need to go and break some
trail and figure out where I'm going
because it's going to get really hard to
navigate
I'm in the wrong place this Ridge dead
ends in a Razor's Edge my map wasn't
detailed enough
there's no way I can get through those
altars and it just
I'd have to go down this Valley and up
some extremely steep slopes through some
very thick brush I'm just it's just not
an option problem is even if I did beat
through all this brush I'm not done I
still have about a mile to go till I get
to the plateau then on the other side of
the mountains I've got to go through
terrain very similar to this again if I
break some equipment or pull a muscle I
am very far from help this just is
feeling like a bad idea the only way I'm
getting out of here is in my own two
feet
and I can't go that way
well I'm quickly figuring out that I can
get down this hill gracefully and
quickly I just can't do both at the same
time
it took me two hours to do all that
climbing for five minutes to get down
not having to break Trail is so much
easier
step down and occasionally find these
Hollow spots in the snow and now my
snowshoes trapped oh
everything's more work in the deep snow
oh the sun's set and I'm running on
Twilight I need to go ahead and make ham
and uh this looks as good as a place as
any
well let's find out what's underneath
this snow
this is why I'm having so much trouble
getting up those Hills this snow is so
light and granular just doesn't hold any
weight
[Music]
oh boy oh without my snowshoes I go
straight to the bottom so check out this
big Mass right here under the snow I'm
assuming that that's a root ball from a
tree that's falling over that's going to
make an excellent heat reflector and a
great place to build my fire so if I put
my fire up there against the root ball
I'm going to put my bed right here I
need to build a wall around it to keep
the wind out
foreign
[Music]
's getting a little hard
yeah that's going to be ice pretty soon
I better get a fire going
all right it is getting cold I need to
start finding some firewood
foreign
[Music]
my gloves are soaked I dry these things
out
now that's doing the trick yeah there we
go
hopefully that'll keep my water bottles
from freezing
yeah my blood's not pumping quite as
hard as it was and the air is getting
colder
foreign
[Music]
feels good to sit down I think my next
order of business is get some dinner
ready
well I'm melting some snow for my dinner
but that's going to take a little while
so uh I'm gonna have some little snacks
cheese crackers and salami here got a
feral pig salami from Texas
nice cheese wild boar salami and a Ritz
cracker
wow
got this nice blueberry wensleydale this
is good stuff
also got some dried figs here
all right
I got some instant Korean rice cooking
up and I'm looking forward to that I'm
really hungry and tired and it just
tastes so much better than dehydrated
camping meals oh yeah here we go
I love this boiling bag rice it's just
great for campouts like this little
instant Japanese Curry here just heat
and serve
lived off this stuff though when I was
in Japan
all right curry rice and a piece of
pilot bread to eat with it not too
shabby
all right I got a little bit of dessert
planned I've got some dehydrated creme
brulee not sure how that's gonna work
but you know
we'll see okay all right I'm supposed to
add cold water luckily I know where I
can find some
stir briskly I'm gonna sprinkle the
caramelized sugar on the top
give that a go
it kind of tastes just like butterscotch
pudding but you know a little bit of
creme brulee flavor in there
oh that wasn't too bad that was more
sugar than I usually eat in the whole
day but not too bad
now they got dinner in me I need to do
something about my bed the ground here
is really lumpy there's about a five six
inch dip right there and then there's
like a 10 12 inch dip right there
foreign
uh we'll find out how good of a job I
did tonight hopefully this will hold
there because if not it's going to be a
really miserable night all right moment
of truth well it's been about 30 minutes
and my ugly patch job seems to be
holding air enough air that I think we
can give it a go
well it's nice and level
[Applause]
foreign
down pants we're gonna try
well it's pretty late and I'm very tired
so I'm gonna turn off the camera I'm
gonna see you guys in the morning
oh good morning it's about 6 30 a.m and
uh I think I'm gonna get up I need to
get an early start I've been thinking
about it and I think I figured out how
I'm gonna get out of here without having
to go back up that hill
I think I got a plan B but uh it's it's
pretty cold right now it feels just a
little bit above zero I get that fire
going snowed a bit last night there's
quite a bit of snow on my tarp
if my boot froze to the ground
oh
we got about an inch or two of snow last
night it is really really cold I have
got to get this fire started
[Applause]
oh that's the stuff right there
oh that's nice
I'm in a little bit of a hurry today so
we are gonna bust out our stove because
we got to boil a bunch of water
get some breakfast made
oh my stove's Frozen
ah no matter how clean the snow looks
there's always floaties in it
you get a lot of junk in your water when
you melt snow some of it floats some of
it sinks pour off the first little bit
to get the floaters out and then you
throw away the last little bit so you
don't get the stuff that's on the bottom
in your water that'll take care about 95
percent of the junk I'm in a bit of a
hurry this morning so we're going super
simple instant oatmeal
some instant oatmeal with little bits of
Alder Twigs in it
well it's 8 30 in the morning and I'm
just starting to see some color in this
guy I think it's time for me to get out
of here just kind of use the leftover
water to clean out my cup and then you
drink it melting snow takes forever you
don't waste water
I gotta tell you when that fire was in
there it was toasty warm that was a good
shelter
foreign
for me to make some tracks
I just realized I don't have my glasses
oh boy
yeah I forgot my glasses oh boy
we've been over here
they are not there
yeah they're not there I could not find
them in the shelter and yeah looks like
I'm doing this trip without my glasses
Mr Magoo goes camping
well I had a lot of time last night to
think about it and I think I've come up
with a plan B how I'm gonna get home
it's gonna be a longer hike but it's
going to be flatter so I'm gonna have to
make some serious tracks if I'm gonna
make it where I want to be tomorrow
all right guys I was looking at my map
last night and I think I figured out my
plan B
I'm going to follow these railroad
tracks and they're going to take me the
wrong direction for a lot of miles but
eventually it's going to open up to a
marshy Frozen River Bottom that I can
take around this mountain and get to
where I want to go it's much further but
it's flatter and I won't have to
struggle against the brush as much which
is a big deal because this is flat open
ground I'm going to switch over to my
skis
all right
these Trucking skis float on the snow a
lot better than the snowshoes do so you
don't have to pick your leg up you just
kind of slide across the snow and it
burns a lot less energy but
unfortunately they don't do well
maneuvering around the woods or going up
hills well I got a bit of a rough day
ahead of me and I'm way behind schedule
but look at this this is gorgeous looks
like a Hallmark Christmas special out
here
I'm trying to keep an eye out for moose
without my glasses if I see a moose I am
definitely too close
laughs
so right over there that's the bench I
was trying to get on top of yesterday
I gotta find a way around that
I'm not Crossing this bridge because
it's safe I'm doing it because it's
better than Crossing that Creek
my seal skins keep coming off Seal Skins
are basically synthetic hair that allows
you to slide forward but grips when you
push backwards so it allows you to scoot
across the snow and pull your poke
easily but this bright one is loose
fitting and it keeps coming off every
mile or so hopefully this problem
doesn't get worse but if it does I'll
bust out my snowshoes but that's the
sketchy part of going out in this deep
snow if your snow shoes or your skis
break you're stuck
[Applause]
it out fresh moose tracks one of my big
concerns is I'll come across the Moose
on the tracks and that moose won't get
out of the way for me
seems like every year in Alaska someone
gets attacked by a moose while
cross-country skiing
hey check it out there's somebody's
shovel and their sled right there
someone's got a homestead or a cabin off
in the woods over there and this is
where they come to access the railroad
to get into town to buy supplies when
they come back from town with all their
groceries they'll put it in the sled and
take it off into the woods there's not a
lot of snow on that sled they probably
caught the train that I hopped off of
yesterday when I was on snowshoes I was
averaging about one mile per hour on
this flat terrain with my cross-country
skis I'm doing about 2.4 miles per hour
making much better time
oh we picked up about an extra inch of
snow since I started and it's making the
sled harder to pull you know snow
conditions have a huge impact on your
ability to travel in the winter time if
we were to get a dump of a foot or two
of this light powdery stuff we wouldn't
be able to do diddly squat until the
snow settled and compacted a little bit
check out there's two moose up there on
the hill look how deep they're sinking
their bellies are rubbing in the snow
all right I think I'm gonna take a
little lunch break
you know these cookies aren't as good
Frozen
you need to eat quick I'm starting to
get cold
all right enough lollygagging let's get
going
really happy with my sled
I've been looking to buy a polk for a
number of years finally found one that
was made here in Alaska by a company
called Northern sled Works turns out
they're the same company that makes the
Arctic oven hot tent that I use I'm
really pleased with it it's much lighter
and pulls a lot better than my ice
fishing sleds
oh this snow just keeps coming down it's
getting deeper and deeper
I can't even see my skis anymore
all right there's the bench we've been
trying to get around
oh that's pretty
oh I've been going for about five hours
and uh we're a little more than halfway
done with what I wanted to accomplish
today
it's gonna be a long day today
feet are starting to really kill me I'm
worried I'm gonna start getting blisters
real soon here
I'm making good time but this is taking
it out of me
my feet are getting chewed up I'm a
little worried about whether I'm gonna
make my destination tonight
oh that serious pretty
tired really tired
we're starting to climb over the
foothill of a little mountain here and
you can see the valley to our left and
on the other side that's the mountain we
were trying to get around still got a
long way to go before I get to any
highways or roads
but it's a big milestone but the sun's
gonna sit on me any minute now
thank you
all right guys I've been skiing for
about two hours past Sunset and I am
exhausted it's time to make camp but I
made really good time and uh I'm On
Target so I'm feeling good about what we
did today
oh
oh that poke tried to pull me off my
feet
hey let's find a spot now that's looking
pretty good right in there
foreign
[Music]
just waiting for my water to boil so I
can make some tea and make a some dinner
and I am just freezing it has gotten
really cold out with the setting of The
Sun now that I'm not moving it's
it's nippy
I am so cold and so thirsty
took a couple hours but I melted about
three liters of water I got it boiling
hot
just gonna put that in my sleeping bag
all right guys I'm freezing my butt off
I think it's time to go to bed
thanks
so I'm gonna turn this off I'll see you
guys in the morning
hey good morning
it got really cold last night it stopped
snowing and cleared up and the
temperature dropped really aggressively
I think it was around zero once I get
out of the sleeping bag it's it's going
to be bitterly cold so I want to start
moving as soon as I can let's let's do
this my socks were a little wet last
night so I took them off and put them in
my bag
oh they're all nice and dry smell
horrible though okay these puffy pants I
bought are the best thing ever
they are so warm my legs and feet get so
cold at night
my hot water bottles
hopefully that'll defrost them a little
bit
ah
the sweat from my hands made my gloves a
little damp now they're a little bit
Frozen
thank you
foreign
the snow here was so soft yesterday but
after that cold snap last night it's
really firmed up it's going to make life
a lot better just having that snow a
little bit more Frozen makes all the
difference in the world
well last night in the darkness I
finally made it around the toe of the
mountain and I set up camp right after
leaving the railroad tracks so now today
we've got an easy jaw cross flat ground
but I still got a brake Trail and my
legs or feet are very sore
you can't see any landmarks in these
forests so I'm navigating completely by
GPS right now gotta make sure your
batteries are charged you get lost
really easy just going through Straight
Force like this
inches like this will get you soaked so
going
then you don't get snow down the back of
your shirt
just stepped in a tree well
some of the little trees get buried in
the snow and it creates an air pocket
and if you step on one of them you go
all the way down trips you up see all
those Alders right there you walk in
that you'll hit a lot of tree Wells
foreign
I can hear the highway
we're close
oh I think I see it
there we go
oh
we made it
[Music]
the first people I've seen since they
got off the train
well guys they did it not the way I was
planning but I did it I think I broke
about 18 miles of Trail
that is really intense now I just need
to wait for my ride to come
I'm gonna get my jacket out too I'm
already freezing oh it is no joke cold
today all right I think my ride's here
they're a little early is that okay oh
it's wonderful
oh it's so nice to be warm
well guys it made it back safe it's out
and hopefully you guys enjoyed this
video if you want to see more videos
like this check out the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel and click subscribe
because we put out new videos every
Saturday morning all right guys I'll see
you next Saturday
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching